let's see if chris from baltimore can
save us chris you are now on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
okay wow that's crazy
well um
i just wanted to ask a random question
basically like
if you had uh if you were the president
and you had executive order
for you know privileges sure what would
be the first
executive order you passed assuming you
could only do one what would you do
i have no idea it's such a weird i mean
the thing about these questions they're
almost sort of like would you rather
only eat avocados for the next five
years or have to do a thousand sit-ups
before you could drink water each day
it's like i don't know it's unlikely to
ever be a scenario um
if i could oh i don't i don't know what
it would be i mean here's the thing
if i was really going to be in the
position of getting to sign one
executive order
first i would want to be fully briefed
as to all of the things that can even be
done via executive order so that i could
be informed and really evaluate like i
could just say to you oh the first thing
i would do is i would forgive student
dad some student debt or something like
that
if i knew the full scope of what a
president could do via eo
i might say something completely
different so i don't know i'm i'm not
good at these kind of forced questions
let me ask you a question
if if the only breakfast you could eat
for a year was oatmeal with hot dogs in
it or
apples which one would you go with
i see what you're trying to say
i mean
probably the hot dog option wow that's
crazy for me that's an easy question i
would go with the apples but okay that's
fair all right
david thank you so much man i'm a huge
fan my pleasure thanks for calling in
there's chris
from baltimore um let's take a very
quick break if you're holding
hang on for me we're gonna go right back
to the phones in a moment